every game needs a mascot League of
Legends has Teemo Rainbow six has two
chunka and dota 2 as gaben I can be
reached at game and gaben gaben gaben at
valve software comm sure those aren't
the mascots chosen by the game
publishers themselves but oftentimes
fans will choose their own for the games
that they love all they need is a mean
and for counter-strike that symbol of
solidarity is chicken video games have
been obsessed with chickens for years
from the slowly decaying chicken ometer
of attic attack to Streets of Rage 2 s
chicken cold dole sidewalk to the
vengeful poultry of Zelda everyone's
favorite white meat keeps finding its
way into games but csgo is iconic fowl
mascot didn't actually begin its journey
and counter-strike in fact it was lifted
from another game entirely the chicken
model that appeared in the original
counter-strike was hatched in a 1998
quake 2 mod called catch the chicken it
was basically a capture the flag mode
where the flag was replaced with a
clearly agitated [__] the mod was
popular enough that to map designers
Glen Cooper and Jason green borrowed the
chicken model while working on Italy for
counter-strike in 2000 they wanted to
give the map an identity so they added
things like classical Italian music the
played in specific areas
[Music]
unique textures and of course the
chickens while they kind of looked like
chickens they might have been even more
brainless in the actual bird standing
around pecking the ground completely
ignorant to the chaotic war zone
surrounding I don't know that sounds
pretty realistic to me
[Music]
Oh holiday the chickens eternal cycle of
death and rebirth was mercifully halted
in 2004 with their exclusion from
counter-strike source but that reprieve
was short-lived as that same year valve
release condition zero which featured
minor cameos from our feathered
flightless friends who had developed
another barnyard language eight years
later valve released csgo
which boasted not just an improved
tactical FPS experience but upgraded
chickens as well Global offensives birds
weren't just visually more believable no
they were also given AI making them
mobile and reactive to sound and
movement chickens were no longer
shackled to their spawn points they were
given free range of the map to die
wherever they pleased
[Music]
while the war seasoned fowl has been
part of Counter Strike for 20 years it
was in global offensive that it truly
became the series mascot they can be
found occupying a number of the maps
most notably Kabul and Inferno and you
can even treat them like pets the dreams
alive chickens but most importantly in
csgo the chickens are woke their battle
wise birds who won't hesitate to run
from danger and over the years this
immersion mechanic has actually impacted
Pro matches occasionally providing
crucial visual cues for players but
chickens aren't always beneficial to a
player holding an angle sometimes they
can wander in front of your crosshairs
and even take a bullet for the enemy and
most frustratingly
they're even capable of blocking doors
buh has done a massive job 10 seconds
left Rox has to hold onto it
chicken blocking the door I've not seen
that for that gets it killed oh my god a
chicken blocking the door just got
robbed skilled that's right
csgo gave chickens real power the power
to kill because of the potential risk
they presented players would kill
chickens on site if possible and in 2013
valve reacted to this seemingly cruel
trend by quieting the chicken squawks
and reducing the chances of them running
while chickens will still run if they
hear gunfire oddly they don't care about
silenced weapons going off right next to
them
[Music]
to find out why that is we went straight
to our source
Charles chickens look we've lived in war
zones for almost 20 years
so when we hear a gun fire it
invigorates us we do not flee from
silence we may be chickens but we're not
chicken [__]
get that mic out of my face mother
clucker anyway despite being inherently
at a place the cs community has really
latched on a chicken and it makes
perfect sense considering they're the
most whimsical hilarious part of the
game over the years chickens have become
fuel for some of cs COEs most potent
memes from fan movies about them rising
up in revenge to an actual chicken
predicting the results at the London
major don't be a chicken
anxious in anticipation can we just
confirm that there's food in both sides
yeah you're right Oh up to the platform
[Applause]
there was even the complicated saga of a
player named chicken hilariously
invading pro game lobbies at ESL one
Katowice in 2015 chicken in the lobby
yeah really you really wants to play yes
you could rank its will I you can see
that yes the level to play this
semifinal you know valve has even
encouraged chicken fandom by making
merchandise gun stickers and supporting
regular holiday updates the gift
chickens funny attire like during
Halloween when they were turned into
ghosts and zombies which allowed them to
seek vengeance on the bastards that
murder them in the first place
or you know just to get blown to pieces
again and fans absolutely love these
efforts by valve to recognize their
sacred bird because without the
community chicken wouldn't be what it is
today
they took a goofy pointless Easter Egg
and elevated it first into a meme and
then into a mascot hey miles why did the
chicken cross pit I don't know why to
get to the other site god it sounds like
a Steven Seagal movie right
[Music]
[Laughter]
Kaju I never give the ball